je suis assez ému que l'année Richie
soit présent que je l'ai en face de moi
quand même parce que c'est youce pour
moi c'est une chanson culte et une belle
chanson d'amour puisque c'est pendant
ces youce Émile j'ai connu mon premier
fils fucking
là il y en areci est-ce que j'ai compris
un truc je vais me lancer dans la
chanson
[Rires]
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes bien en
France est-ce que vous êtes heureux
quand vous êtes en France
je suis très très bien ici en France
très très bien qu'est-ce que vous
préférez en France
ça compte aussi disons que dans mes
années de jeunesse avec les commodors il
a tout à fait raison c'était les
Françaises bon et la vie
les gens la cuisine tout ça c'était
sympa maintenant j'aime toujours les
filles les Français j'aime toujours la
ville j'ai toujours la cuisine française
ils ont quelque chose n'ont pas beaucoup
changé mais disons que le public a
toujours été très loyal très fidèle
alors c'est vrai la Lionel qu'à l'époque
des Commodores au début des Commodores
avant le succès vous allez chanter sur
la scène du Byblos à Saint-Tropez
imaginez-vous cette scène il y avait
c'était une époque où il y avait Mick
Jagger qui venait d'épouser Bianca si je
ne m'abuse il y avait le groupe Air qui
était enfin c'était la comédie musicale
du siècle et puis tout le monde venait à
Saint-Tropez
et alors
en fait le spectacle était littéralement
dans la salle je suis assez ému que la
Lionel Richie soit présent en face de
moi quand même parce que c'est youce
pour moi c'est une chanson culte et une
belle chanson d'amour puisque c'est
pendant say youcefucking
[Applaudissements]
100 millions d'albums vendus
millions d'albums vendus 30 millions
avec les Commodores et 70 millions quand
il a été tout seul comme quoi vous avez
bien fait de partir alors 20 top tenes
énormes 20 octets vous avez été couvert
de récompenses et surtout en 1984 lors
des Jeux olympiques de Los Angeles
il a chanté all night long devant 2,3
milliards de téléspectateurs
[Rires]
vous êtes né en 1949 dans l'Alabama dans
une petite ville qui s'appelle
tuskiji et vous êtes revenu maintenant
vous habitez de nouveau dans la dans
cette ville-là
même si j'habite en fait à Beverly Hills
avec ma famille bonjour le jour j'ai
toujours une maison sur le campus
universitaire l'anniversité là-bas alors
votre adolescence a été marqué par deux
grands hommes Martin Luther King et
Malcolm X qui ont été d'ailleurs
assassinés tous les deux alors à
l'époque vous venez d'entrer à
l'université de tesskiji 166 et quand
vous entendez parler d'un mouvement qui
se forme parmi les jeunes noirs et dans
l'objectif et de répondre à la violence
des blancs par la violence des blacks là
il y a pas de discussion possible ça
s'appelle les Black Panther bien entendu
et vous en faites partie pourquoi en
c'est à dire un an après avez-vous
quitté les les Black Panthers
un petit peu idéaliste lorsqu'on a 19
ans on se dit que l'on peut vraiment
faire une différence que l'on peut faire
changer le monde et je me suis rendu
compte que les Black Panthers voulaient
trouver le pouvoir tout en restant dans
la ségrégation tout en restant isolé du
reste du monde mais moi au contraire je
cherchais l'intégration avec le reste de
la société alors je me suis rendu compte
que à cette époque j'avais un choix soit
je rejoignais les commodors soit je
restais avec les Black Panthers parce
que la musique était plus simple vous
avez refusé le communautarisme alors
l'autre influence que vous avez subi
c'est celle du pasteur Martin Luther
King et a eu un moment vous avez vous
avez eu envie de devenir prêtre vous
vouliez vous vouliez devenir prêtre
c'est tout à fait vrai voilà mais au
moment d'entrer au séminaire l'anal
Ricci a rencontré les commodor
alors là avec les Commodores la galère
commence à combien de temps avez-vous
mis avec les Commodores pour faire votre
premier tube ah oui oui
avant avant de faire notre premier tube
donc c'était
j'avais déjà terminé ma première année à
l'université et puis après ça on a donc
on a quitté de l'école c'est là qu'on a
commencé à faire de la musique à temps
plein
ça a mis énormément de temps alors
l'autre personne qui a eu beaucoup
d'influence aussi dans votre vie la
Lionel Richie c'est Michael Jackson
d'abord parce que vous êtes passé en
première partie des Jackson Five à
teskiji et ça vous a lancé parce que
dans la salle ce soir là c'est bérégordi
le patron de la TAM la motarde qui était
dans la salle et quand il vous a vu en
première partie de Jackson Five il vous
a signé tout de suite voilà ça a été
très important et l'autre moment l'autre
moment où Michael Jackson
très important aussi dans votre vie
c'est quand vous veniez d'être évincé
d'une certaine façon par les Commodores
et Michael Jackson vous a dit continue
tout seul c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
planté mes frangins depuis je suis une
énorme star il venait de faire Off The
Wall et donc vous avez fait pareil et
vous avez vendu deux fois plus d'album
tout seul voilà alors avec Michael
Jackson vous avez composé tous les deux
cette magnifique chanson maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup entendu je
suis d'accord mais c'est quand même une
belle chanson qui s'appelle We Are The
World ça s'est passé comment vous étiez
où quand vous l'avez écrit de cette
chanson
mais j'étais à Los Angeles je j'ai reçu
un appel de Harry Belafonte qui m'a dit
voilà on a tous ces groupes qui
voudraient faire quelque chose pour
sauver la famille en Afrique et il
cherche des chanteurs des artistes noirs
il fallait faire quelque chose donc j'ai
contacté Christine José et et on a on
j'allais écrire une chanson avec Stevie
Wonder j'appelle Stevie on n'arrivait
pas à se coordonner alors j'ai n'était
juste à côté on va essayer de travailler
avec lui on s'est retrouvé au studio et
puis là on a décidé qu'on allait il y
aurait quatre personnes Stevie Quincy et
moi-même alors on était au studio et
c'est là que la rumeur s'est répandue
que nous allions écrire cette chanson et
bien tous les artistes nous ont appelé
pour nous demander s'il pouvait faire
partie de ce groupe alors il y avait
quelques 45 artistes qui se sont engagés
à nos côtés et puis on se dit bah voilà
on va faire ça la veille des Music
Awards à Los Angeles et c'est là que bon
moi j'étais l'animateur de l'émission et
et on a quitté le spectacle et de 10
heures du soir à 1h du matin le
lendemain on a donc enregistré et on a
fait d'ailleurs la vidéo de We Are The
World là une Richie avec we are the
world on est loin de George wouches
parce que lui c'est plutôt i am the
world alors
vous faites partie des Américains qui
veulent aller faire la guerre en Irak ou
plutôt des Américains qui pensent que
c'est une énorme connerie
c'est parce que la politique a échoué
parce que la diplomatie a échoué et je
crois que vraiment c'est vraiment le
tout dernier recours c'est d'aller
envoyer des gens à la guerre parce que
ça fait ça veut dire que le dialogue
était épuisé et il y a quand même plein
de gens intelligents sur terre il va y
avoir moyen quand même d'établir un
dialogue c'est pas possible on peut
dépenser des milliards des milliards de
dollars pour acheter des machines de
guerre et faire la guerre à tort et à
travers mais on peut faire beaucoup plus
de choses avec cet argent il y a une
famine qui règne un peu partout dans le
monde il y a des problèmes d'éducation
il y a plein de choses qu'on pourrait
faire avec cet argent je crois que la
toute dernière chose à faire c'est de
dépenser cet argent pour faire la guerre
pour construire des bombes et que
sais-je essayons plutôt de nous servir
de la diplomatie pour sauver les choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cela dit cela dit d'autre part
si vraiment la diplomatie échoue bon
mais il faut faire ce qu'il faut faire
là maintenant nous sommes arrivés au
stade où
j'ai l'impression que nous avons atteint
le point de nos retours disons que la
diplomatie doit être quand même le
facteur primordial ce qui m'inquiète
j'ai l'impression que nous sommes allés
probablement aller trop loin dans tous
les sens je ne sais pas d'ailleurs où
cela va aboutir est-ce que vous croyez
pas que il faudrait désormais d'urgence
c'est des États-Unis
où je me dis ce serait quand même bien
de pas pousser le bouchon aussi loin
qu'on le fait disons que et là je me
rappelle ce que me disait mon père
lorsqu'il me conseillait sur le mariage
il disait ça s'applique également dans
ce cas là il y a des il y a des moments
où il faut arrêter de discuter il faut
quelquefois écouter et on apprend
beaucoup plus de choses en écoutant
qu'en parlant et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu